there were about 168 blue screen shots
in this one little sequence i'm going to
be inclined to say this guy's cg all the
way up until right here
this is ridiculous but isn't it cool
yeah no it's amazing
we spent probably seven months talking
about how we were going to shoot it can
i guess how you did it before uh yes
please do
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artists react
we are joined here by joe farrell he's
incredibly accomplished he's worked on a
ton of films that you've watched that
you've heard of that you love including
uh most recently being a visual effects
supervisor on chongqi yeah i was the
additional visual effects supervisor
mainly working on the second unit i
absolutely adore being on set a lot of
people don't because onset can have vast
periods of time at boredom shang chi was
far from boring i just smiled from ear
to ear working on this film because it
was so much fun oh and clint's here
welcome back clint good to be back
thanks for having me good to have you
back man yeah it feels like uh it feels
like i never left all right let's jump
in let's just jump on in
you have the wrong guy does he look like
he can fight come on bro so there's a
lot of talk about this bus sequence that
we did because of the pandemic we had
shoot about five different countries in
the world and brought together by
artists all working from home so it was
quite an achievement and quite a
spectacular sequence
i mean it's a fight scene right so i got
a comment on the fight it's like that's
so classic jackie with the whole jacket
thing and it just comes from bro you
know exactly so brad allen which
unfortunately he passed away recently he
bought his stunt team he'd been working
with over the years with jackie chan and
the stunt crew over there that
department was a powerhouse with this
movie andy uh the stunt supervisor for
this sequence i think he'd spent many
years working with jackie and he was
definitely channeling the use of all
garments and definitely utilizing the
bus itself the bus became part of the
fight and becomes quite integral to the
entire sequence we had a total of four
buses two of them we had to modify for
real stunt work and then the other two
were one of them was on some air
bladders and the other one we had
elevated up on this amazing rig where
they could hold the whole bus and
articulate it like 40 degrees to 30
degrees so young lee and chris
they actually designed with brad allen
and they put together a whole previous
for this right i would assume i believe
it's called stunt views so initially
what happens is they stunt visit they
work out the whole fight sequence with
similar cameras to what you're using we
then needed to as the visual effects
department would come in and previews
all the pieces that integrated with that
got you so they would then modify the
stunt fizz according to what we had
previous and it was a back and forth
process to finally get this
so all this is shot on blue screen in
sydney oh really yeah well i come from a
compositing background and so my pet
peeve is car comps purely because of
just simple things that you can do that
sometimes go missed and make it look
fake such as i'm not going to tell you
i was like i want to know no no that's
my secret sauce no all right yeah i'll
tell you there were about 168 blue
screen shots in this one little sequence
yeah so looking at this right there's a
bunch of blurry edges and they're
perfect edges right how do you pull blue
screen keys like this that give you
perfect edges attention to detail tiny
sections where we're pulling out an area
there and redoing it and doing a
luminance key here and an edge there or
a hand paint fix here and there gotcha
so when you have something that has like
blurry edges you're basically going and
doing little tiny masks around each one
of those and doing a specific key for
each edge depending on what kind of edge
it is correct yeah i mean you could get
lucky and do an amazing overall key and
pull it off but i think that was
probably 0.001 chance of that actually
happening i think you'll find the 99.9
of the time it is just the artists
working really really hard to achieve
that goal yeah this is only a fraction
of the scene too this goes on for like
10 minutes it's like a ridiculous i
think i think it's 5 minutes and 32
seconds or something long i know i
literally worked on this sequence for a
year and a half we needed to choreograph
it in such a detail because all the
people that are on the bus they move
around we're pulling out chairs we're
pulling out poles they had to pull the
windows off because a lot of the times
the reflections are just the crew
goodness so you're adding back in the
reflections and the windows and of
course the background too when we're
shooting inside those reflections are
natural the interesting part is actually
the arrays and what's going on outside
so you've got people standing out there
you've got blowers you've got people
rocking it you've got lights that come
in reflectors the speed at which you're
moving at you can't prevent them from
being in the shot you'll do what you can
you're like can we move the reflector
and the dp will be like all right i can
move him out here is that any better for
you but you're moving at such a speed we
do these setups every sort of 20 minutes
so if you imagine moving 200 people
every 20 minutes oh yeah
that shot we spent probably seven months
talking about how we were going to shoot
it because it's a very very complicated
shot can i guess how you did it before
uh yes please do clint this is our
chance all right sherlock holmes this
with the person right in front of us
that can actually tell us how it's done
put on the goggles he's probably not
even touching razer fist right raises a
separate plate and then he's his own
plate and then the background is
probably another plate and then the back
background is probably another plate
right i'm tempted to say that his jacket
is cg but perhaps his entire body is cg
i can also see that he's like on wires
or something where is he being picked
from is it the hips and then you got to
get that out of there so the shirt is
redone completely and the legs probably
aren't even real and then you're
transitioning out boom to a different
shot of him right there all right you
guys want to let me tell you or you want
to keep going yeah
you're kind of getting there it's a real
jacket it's a real shirt it's real cemu
and it's real legs it's a cg razor the
entire bus the foreground background and
everything else is cg oh it's way easier
that way yeah
so much easier and are you doing a
transition on them or is this one long
take where you actually move the camera
this move happens over four seconds and
it travels 22 feet the camera just goes
like that yeah and we tried getting a
motion control camera to shoot it but we
couldn't get it into the country the
pandemic caused us not to be able to get
the milo so really what it is is it's a
rail and had it so that the camera would
drop through a pulley system and they
would jump off these ladder and fall and
it's all landing on blue screen so all
the lighting you're seeing here is the
artistry of the luma compositor who did
this and us just saying all right let's
bring more interaction to it and you
know hopefully we did a good job it
looks great
i saw this i was like rush hour too you
know jackie going up the thing running
up the bamboo and everything yeah this
sequence was pretty special
[Music]
the way that camera just like swoops and
then becomes grounded and real suddenly
it's like you barely notice like this is
all crazy crazy crazy and boom real
people
[Music]
i joke about this sequence because i
think he kills seven people in this
sequence
but he does it in such a charlie chaplin
way that i think that it doesn't really
bother anybody
but he does murder that man dies poor
49ers i mean that guy might have a
family i don't know
[Music]
i love these kind of falls brutal all
right so this shot right here
i'm going to be inclined to say this
guy's cg all the way up until right
here now it's real i think the beginning
is real and i think the end is real or
you could do the whole thing for real
for real because it's really hard to say
because there's this marvel gloss that's
like on every marble film yeah and it
makes the cg and all the compositing and
all the real stuff all blend together
really really well i would say that um
pretty much from the outside chris said
we shoot as much real as we possibly can
cool so with this particular shot the
two guys on the left are real and the
guy on the right he's digital all the
way through to the end due to the
amazing animation done by rodeo fx we
did actually have a performer doing that
but we needed to just tweak it enough
that it pulled it out of the live action
so you ended up with really good
reference yes
yes he drops three stories down and he
swings around he does this kind of move
but he needs to do it in a way that's
threatening he's trying to come down
with the purpose of taking out shang chi
and so i think destin suggested that we
go with having him come and just kick
really hard and we watch many videos of
parkour guys and they tuck up really
tight and then explode out and that's
sort of a very sort of martial arts kind
of move and we thought that would sort
of sit nicely i'm not a fan of sort of
you know losing weight on on cg
characters
even if it's a little heavier than you
would expect that's better it's better
to lean a little bit into that yeah and
what we're looking at here in the
background is the scaffolding actually
there yeah
everything's digital but because it's
all on a mirrored surface it's
reflecting the environment and if you
notice the camera never once stays still
in this entire sequence so the camera
constantly moving means all those
reflections had to be individually
rendered
and this one has about 110 shots in the
sequence and so their black uniform on a
very dark night in a dark city the
lighting and the billboard placement all
needed to be meticulously done so that
you could silhouette everything that's
really really clever and also incredibly
time consuming that's ridiculous and a
lot of the time we actually were
confused what direction the camera was
facing you needed to know that you were
looking at a building rather than
looking through scaffolding at the city
on the other side interesting and so we
did a lot of work and actually trying to
figure out how the reflection looked
when you knew specifically when you were
looking at the city versus the
reflection you see all the reflections
have a slight lift in their densities to
help with the readability oh i see it's
like all the black levels have been kind
of just bumped slightly so even the
darkest part of the reflection is still
slightly brighter than the darkest part
of the people in front of it correct but
that obviously meant that we needed to
split the reflection off from the main
one so they needed to even more roto
this is ridiculous complicated
it's ridiculous but isn't it cool yeah
it's amazing
hey to all y'all that have just stumbled
upon vfx artist react for the first time
consider subscribing you're gonna have a
good time lots of other people have kept
coming back
i think you're gonna be one of them so i
heard that you snuck a shot into this
movie snuck a shot
you snuck something in we always in
visual effects try and sneak something
in no i mean you know there's all this
talk about sort of virtual camera work
and all the technology that's coming
along with mandalorian and there's a
shot in this one particular one where i
did a virtual camera work but it's so
old school that it's amazing you can
take old-fashioned techniques and just
apply them right into the middle of
something so complex
it's at the end right the helicopter no
it's in the beginning it's right in the
beginning three shots
i know exactly
it's 57 frames long
oh my god it is probably not right here
the reason it was so interesting and
difficult is because when you're
pre-visiting shots you can go out to a
previous company and you say look
there's a billboard there's a helicopter
and there's an explosion but when you
actually try and put it into a 239
aspect the audience needs to know what
they're looking at instantly because the
shot is only just over two seconds long
you've got a little hint of the
billboard up until that point now the
problem with the billboard is it's a
giant light source and you don't want
the people going look a billboard and
then the shot's gone and you're like
hang on how is he now doing that and why
is the window gone you don't want that
confusion we did a couple of versions in
previews and we're trying to throw
different ideas a camera up top looking
down and then a camera coming around the
back but all of those things would sort
of miss one of those factors you
wouldn't see the billboard you would
only see the explosion so i ended up
taking my son's model aeroplane
suspending it on a ruler with a piece of
nylon string getting two chairs and then
just basically framed the chairs knowing
where the billboard was and i would just
do different kinds of camera moves just
filming this little model aircraft and
then i would take that i'd track it and
try different ideas and change different
speeds and then tweak it and then ended
up generating a camera to show that to
the director and they loved it and that
was my version of a virtual camera i'd
love to see the like the official marvel
breakdown where it's like doing all the
wipes and then it just shows like it
shows mike
it just shows my garage in a model thing
it seems like your solution was just to
simply have a shot that orbited started
kind of focused on the billboard and
then turned our attention over to where
the explosion happened kind of pivoting
around the helicopter in the center yeah
the helicopter was not as important the
billboard was sort of like reasonably
important but in this particular one
that explosion kept getting bigger and
bigger and bigger because we needed to
draw your eye to it it's a great lesson
on clarity because it's so important if
your audience is confused then who cares
it doesn't matter nothing matters that's
a great story though i love that it's
like you do what you can with what you
got and like you don't have to do the
whole thing you make it work you know
this is actually fairly traditional
movie making on this film it looks
technologically savvy and we are using
amazing technology and we have all the
gadgets and all the gizmos and amazing
rigs and so on but it's all just real
sets real rigs that are really moving
there's no fantastical shots in here and
if there is a fantastical shot it's
actually done with rigs that can now do
fantastical things for people out there
who've been wanting to get into this as
a career do you have any suggestions for
anybody who's trying to get into it
don't get into it unless you're
passionate you have to be passionate if
you're not you won't survive so i'm just
ridiculously passionate about movie
making or just storytelling and being
able to do it in any way shape or form
that i can is why i i enjoy the cinema
that's awesome you guys may have heard
of the series jim connor where ken block
goes out there and does incredible stunt
driving well joe here made his own
version with the sun called koala khanna
where they took a little tesla plastic
toy yeah we found it in the rubbish and
we did it up to crazy and we do about 20
miles they modded it
they like built their own battery and
stuff yeah it's actually really good and
a great example of some awesome
filmmaking you can just do on your own
with buddies or whomever it only has
like 300 views i think it'd be really
cool to give it the uh the old vpx rsv
let's try and get to 500 views
let's give it a little love here and
bump that up we certainly appreciate it
i think it'd be really cool
hey everybody it's me jake here back for
another brand integration with today's
sponsor squarespace now i heard that
jordan has been doing these integrations
lately and well i don't want her to take
my job so i've come back to do these
integrations using state-of-the-art
technology and i'm just happy to be here
but i'm even happier to tell you guys
about today's sponsors squarespace
squarespace is the best way for people
that don't know how to build a website
to build a website and they have a bunch
of different features that you can get
when you use them first and foremost
they have 24 7 award-winning customer
service and award-winning templates
don't forget that you can create a
members-only area on your squarespace
website and have members only benefits
that appear in that section it's pretty
great say you're part of a little bit of
a bigger team well guess what with
squarespace's multiple contributors
tools you can assign different roles and
use the strengths that different people
are good at to contribute to your
website with squarespace's unmatched
traffic overviews tools just like how
this robot records everything in the
studio all the time squarespace's
traffic overviews are going to record
who comes to your site what pages they
land on and give you an overview of what
their experience is like so that you can
better tailor your website to who's ever
visiting
with squarespace you can use their
social media tools to post one time on
your squarespace website and then have
that post automatically format and go
out to your other social media profiles
it makes posting across multiple
profiles a heck of a lot easier a lot
more effective and it's going to save
you a bunch of time and probably some
money so if you're interested in getting
some amazing technology for yourself
head on over to squarespace.com
or crew and you get 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain that's squarespace.com
corridor or just click the link in the
description below oh hey christian um i
need to do a meeting with nico right now
do you think you could carry me upstairs
thanks thanks
yeah this is this is great i know i'm
kind of heavy
[Music]
so we often ask for what are your
favorite shots from films tv shows
classic films i would love to know what
some of your favorite vfx from youtube
videos and other online creators i'd
love to do a breakdown of some of the
stuff that we've seen on youtube from
some of the wonderful digital artists
here also if you are a big fan of this
show and love to have longer episodes we
actually do extended episodes on our
website they're cut a little bit slower
we go a little deeper into the knowledge
it's a good time quarterdigital.com
check it out joe thank you immensely for
joining us yes it was my pleasure
anytime you guys want to invite me onto
this therapeutic couch i'm here don't
forget also check out clint's channel at
youtube.com yeah i'm you know teaching
people how to do vfx in my weird way so
come on over hanging out it's a good
time all right joe thank you so much to
all of you watching thank you so much
we'll see you either this sunday
tomorrow because we have another video
usually on sundays or next saturday if
you don't watch our other videos for
some reason